hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called the
last flight spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie opens up in an empty
airplane where the flight attendant Mina
suddenly wakes up surprisingly she
doesn't recall how she ended up here she
screams for her boyfriend and
fortunately he arrives in consoles the
boyfriend appears to be the pilot of the
aircraft suddenly the emergency door
opens and he is sucked out of the plane
the site horrifies Mina and she tries
her best to save herself but eventually
she also meets the same fate as her
husband the next second Mina wakes up on
a bus it turns out everything was just a
dream she along with her colleagues are
on a tropical island they are soon
flying to Singapore and the pilot is
none other than Mina's boyfriend Charles
here we get to know that the two
recently broke up and that's why they
are acting so called towards one another
later during the check-in we are
introduced to an entitled mixed couple
Kevin and Melissa they are rich
Americans who think they are better than
everyone because they paid for the first
class seats when Kevin is stopped for
holding a pocket knife he argues that he
should be allowed to take it because of
his status at the same airport a group
of five young tourists is on its way
back home after a month-long vacation
one of them named Daniel has brought
with him something that is not allowed
on the airplane in front of him is a
little girl traveling with her blind
grandmother Daniel pretends to show her
a magic trick and secretly puts his
stuff into her bag fortunately for him
the bag passes through without the
security officers noticing in the
following scene all the passengers board
the plane since they are traveling off
season there are only nine of them the
flight attendants are at ease because it
is an easy day at work for them among
the group of young people are a couple
named Sophie and Max Max is a hard
worker and has been on his laptop the
entire trip his girlfriend frequently
tells him to pay her more attention but
he never listens Sophie's understanding
of her boyfriend's nature but is always
hungry for his attention which she
doesn't know is that Max has just bought
their dream apartment and is about to
surprise her when they land in Singapore
Charles welcomes the passenger aboard
and wishes everyone a comfortable flight
as he talks to a flight attendant it is
revealed that the airlines have gone
through a massive cross-cutting recently
which means they have been provided just
enough fuel for the trip it is not an
ideal situation for a pilot but Charles
is confident the trip will be safe
finally the plane takes off and reaches
its desired height safely Daniel is with
his sister who tries to engage in a
conversation but he is distracted by his
stuff in the little girl's bag the
economy class is interrupted when the
blind woman gets off her seat in panic
she claims that they are all going to
die and begs the flight attendant to
land immediately they eventually manage
to calm her down and everyone thinks she
is just paranoid in the meantime Mina
goes to the cockpit to check up on the
pilots she comments that the Moon looks
closer today to which Charles reveals
that what they are seeing is a super
moon that occurs once every year it is
also revealed that Mina is set to be a
professional pilot next year and her
instructor is Charles outside a flight
attendant named Jessica goes to Zao a
member of Sophie and Max's group he
flirts with Jessica and the two
instantly seem to hit it off a while
later everyone falls asleep and Zao goes
to the supply room to meet her they
secretly sneak into the business class
bathroom and start making out while
walking out of the bathroom Zao bumps
into Sophie he quickly brings her aside
so she won't know Jessica is still
inside the bathroom as they talk we find
out that Sophie is having an affair with
Zhao behind her boyfriend's back while
Max is busy working for their future has
been sneaking around his back throughout
the entire trip Zao tells her that he
loves her and asks her to break up with
Max as soon as possible Sophie promises
to do so after they land unaware that
Zao is playing her Jessica is still in
the bathroom when she notices a shadow
behind her that disappears pretty
quickly so she doesn't think about it
too much Sophie returns to her seat and
fondly watches the little girl draw in
the front seat then she notices a
strange drawing of a girl with two guys
who look too much like Sophie and her
Partners the drawing shocks her but she
assumes it is a coincidence and focuses
on Max instead Mina comes back to the
supply room and finds a damaged package
with half-eaten food inside it before
she can investigate what happened a
locker moves on its own and attacks her
sometime later a scream is heard from
the supply room as it turns out
Jessica's dead body was found covered in
scratches from some kind of animal
everyone gathers up in a panic not
knowing what to do Charles takes control
of the situation and asks everyone to be
seated the Singapore police will be on
the runway when they land and will take
care of the situation until then no one
is allowed to go near the dead body Max
wants Charles to let him investigate the
death because he has experience in
forensic science upon getting a closer
look at Jessica's wound he finds out the
scratches are poisonous and a human
couldn't have done it Charles refuses to
believe it because there is no possible
way for an animal that dangerous to
board the plane without anyone knowing
Kevin overhears the conversation in the
cockpit and loses his mind he creates a
scene calling everyone a coward and
asking the pilot to do something so
suddenly the lights go off and the
electronic devices stop working Charles
sends his co-pilot down to the electric
room to fix the problem he remains
downstairs for an unnaturally long time
worrying Mina hence after waiting for a
while she decides to look for him Max
also joins her in the two find a
co-pilot's dead body with similar
scratches rushing back to the cockpit
they tell Charles what they found the
mission control claims that they are
working with who to figure out what the
problem is but an emergency landing is
impossible because of an impending storm
while waiting for the storm to pass Max
fears for his and Sophie's life hence he
tells her about the house he bought them
Sophie is overwhelmed by the surprise
and feels extremely guilty for cheating
on him their moment is interrupted by a
yelling Melissa she runs downstairs with
scratches on her body having survived
the Animal by seconds everyone runs to
help her except Daniel who goes to the
little girl to ask for his stuff he
aggressively looks through her bag but
the thing he hid there is missing when
he starts yelling at the little girl The
Others Stop him and inquire what is
wrong this is when he reveals that he
had brought a cat fossil with him from
the tropical island he did it out of
curiosity because the fossil looked
expensive Kevin attacks him blaming him
for hurting his wife although Daniel
insists that the cat was dead and
harmless he doesn't have an explanation
for how it disappeared Kevin is a second
away from killing Daniel when the
captain makes an announcement that stops
him he asks the injured passengers to
flush their system in and out with water
to help with the pain Charles has just
made contact with the officials from the
island and found out that a similar cat
fossil was found on it although they
appear to be dead at first they can be
extremely dangerous the extent of their
abilities is unknown but the locals have
been warned to stay away from them his
Panic sets in among the passengers Zhao
starts hitting Daniel when Max tries to
stop him Zao discloses his relationship
with Sophie NAX looks at his girlfriend
for reassurance but the look on her face
makes it clear that Zao is telling the
truth suddenly they hear a noise from
upstairs Daniel follows it to take care
of the situation himself since he is the
one who started it a while later his
sister comes looking for him and is
attacked as well when the others run to
see what's up they find the siblings on
the floor heavily injured but not dead
yet they say that the cat is too quick
and they could barely see it when it
moved around Mina panics and calls
Charles but he cannot come out of the
cockpit without his co-pilot in charge
he asks everyone to stay in the business
class and lock the doors just when the
passengers think they are safe the
overhead compartments start making
noises Zao feels the monster cat nearby
and knows that it will attack him if he
makes a slight movement to save himself
he tells the old lady that her
granddaughter is in trouble she gets up
and becomes an easy target for The Cat
In the End she dies because of the
poisonous injury Sophie confronts Zao
for being an awful person and finally
realizes she made a mistake in Judgment
of character at the same time Mina finds
a bunch of drawings made by the little
girl they depict the events that have
happened till now which means that she
can somehow see the future after that
the passengers decide to barricade the
doors to the business class except for
Daniel and his sister who stays in the
toilet where there is plenty of water
Daniel starts humming a song to calm his
sister down but instead it attracts the
monster he then locks his sister out of
the toilet to fight the cat on its own
she runs to others for help and Daniel
follows her a while later another
problem arises when Kevin refuses to
share water bottles with anyone except
his wife he breaks the handles of a
suitcase and uses it as a weapon to warn
everyone to stay away this causes an
altercation between him and Daniel and
Daniel is killed in the end Kevin turns
more robe by the second thinking they
won't survive the plane ride but Mina
calms him down by showing him a drawing
that depicts the plane landing safely
since it was drawn by the little girl
they believe it will be their future
later on Charles is informed that they
cannot land in Singapore because of a
tropical storm the nearest and fastest
they can land is at the finfu airport in
Bhutan Kevin figures out the plane is
ascending yet again and yells at Charles
to land no matter what the weather is in
Singapore in an attempt to calm everyone
down Charles informs the past passengers
that an antitoxin will be provided to
the injured as soon as they land Kevin
thinks he is being lied to and gets into
a fight with the guys once again
suddenly a tentacle pierces through his
chest and kills him while the others
watch in shock and Terror with him gone
everyone runs to the cockpit for safety
but they know they will be followed by
the Monstrous cat hence Mina Zao and Max
go outside to set a trap and kill it
they are able to summon it near them but
the cat suddenly attacks Zhao and runs
away Max holds his friends as he
apologizes and dies in his arms next
Mina and Max use a toy to play music and
summon the cat yet again the plan works
and the cat appears in front of them
distracted by the music however trouble
arises When the Music Stops and the cat
gets ready to kill seconds before it
attacks Charles opens an emergency door
and gets sucked out alongside the
monster Nina tries to hold on to him but
soon realizes the cat will also come in
if she pulls Charles inside the airplane
Charles deliberately leaves the Rope
sacrificing himself for the passengers
even while mourning his death death Mina
gets on the pilot seek and lands the
airplane safely the medical team arrives
with antitoxin and everyone aboard is
saved when the chaos ends Mina gets a
call from Charles who turns out to be
alive after falling into the sea and
swimming his way out the movie ends as
they confess that they want to give
their relationship another chance
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching